[Music]
it's Tuesday October night that I just
got a new iMovie plug-in that way no no
that's not that's not me
Phil how you fill me don't feel about if
you don't know what I'm talking about
in fact feel good if you don't know what
I'm talking about especially if you're
under 18 moving on
John yesterday you said that John
Edwards was I think you use the word
schmuck and I'm kind of upset about that
why you're in favor of honest
discussions about presidential politics
yet when you talk about barack obama and
john o'b where do you talk about them as
if one's gut feeling about a
presidential candidate is more important
than what the Kennedy actually plans on
doing once he gets elected as a
presidential politics is like like a
game of poker I don't know about you but
I don't want the presidential election
to be a game of chance I think that
guy's got a good hand he seems confident
I think that guy's bluffing he looks
like kind of a schmuck I don't want this
I want this this is all I care about you
can all sit around and play their games
I don't care I don't care what they look
like when they're holding their cards I
don't care how happy they are when
they're dishing about to me all I care
about is what's on the cards problem if
there's not enough time to actually talk
about what's on the cards there are a
lot of cards in the deck of presidential
politics and apparently many of them are
Apes that's weird
so we obviously can't talk about all the
issues here on Brotherhood 2.0 but as I
tend to believe that the environmental
crisis is the biggest problem that
humanity has ever faced I also tend to
go for the candidate who has strong
environmental policies and john edwards
has very strong environmental policies
and I understand that you the
nerdfighters everyone can and will
disagree with me on that that's what I
believe and that's why I'm an Edwards
man unless he loses in the primary and
then I will be for the next person who
has the strongest environmental record
I'll be honest Barack Obama's up there
he has some good plans but he just
doesn't have nearly as strong of a
global warming policy as John Edwards
does feeling yeah I forgot it should be
screaming he doesn't have nearly as good
a Gomory Posse's John Edwards does Wow
okay hold on let's go back for a second
this is what feuding does to people it's
not healthy
look at that face that being said if I
had to be approached by an entity in an
enchanted forest and it could be a
unicorn or a zombie
I would probably zombies are dead but
they're animals
and there are dead animals but they're
animals the primary job of any animal is
to procreate and that's not something
that we can blame an animal for it
that's what life is about and it's also
I guess what undeath is about so the
undead want to make more undead but
there's only one way to make a dead and
that's to kill the living I'm thinking
it would be preferable to meet something
whose primary mission in life is not to
kill me that is why I went with the
unicorns also unicorns are mixed between
like horses and and like narwhals and
I'm a pretty big fan of narwhals as far
as I'm concerned John feud settled
Edwards
unicorns oh wait if John Edwards was a
zombie unicorn I would probably still
vote for him John I'll see you tomorrow